في خضم العطل الذي اصاب دواليب فرنسا
يتعين على سيده سوفي باغي مديره مركز لطب
الاسنان في الضحيه الباريسيه تامين الحد
الادنى من الرعايه الصحيه للمرضى ولكنها
تقر مساندتها المطلقه للمضربين
انا سيده مولوده على 67 ومشروع الاصلاح
هذا يمسني بسوء كبير لذلك انا اعارضه بشده
وادعم المضربين دعم مطلقا في القطاع الصحي
الذي افنيت عمري في خدمته ظروف العمل
قاسيه جدا ولا اعتقد ان العاملين فيه
يقدرون على الاستمرار حتى سن الرابعه
والستين زميلات السيده صوفي اخترنا
الاضراب والتظاهر فهن يرفضن جدريا مشروع
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
على الحكومه سحب مشروعها الذي يشكل عقابا
جماعيا مسلطا علينا نحن الذين كسرت ظهور
نا بفعل العمل المضني نضالنا سيستمر
وتحركنا اليوم ليس الا مجرد بدايه ولن
نتوقف عن الاضراب والتظاهر حتى تسحب
الحكومه مشروعها واكرر ان الممرضات لن
يقبلن مطلقا بعامي عمل اضافيين قبل نيل
التقاعد
مئات الالاف من المتظاهرين في باريس رفعوا
شعارات تتهم الحكومه بالتامل على الطبقه
العامله واخرى تتوعد بتعطيل دواليب
الاقتصاد الفرنسي كليا
تظهرنا خمس مرات وصموا اذانهم وكانت هنالك
مظاهرات حشده في مختلف ارجاء فرنسا ولم
يستجيبوا لمطالب الفرنسيين هؤلاء لا
يفهمون الا لغه القوه
[تصفيق]
لم تخلو مظاهره باريس من اعمال شغب
واشتباك مع الشرطه بما يذكر المخاوف من ان
يتخذ الحراك الرافض لاصلاح نظام التقاعد
المنح الذي اتخذه حراك السترات الصفراء من
قبل
مره اخرى تغالب النقابات الرئيسيه في
فرنسا السلطات بان ربطها اصلاح نظام
التقاعد المطروح يستند الى دعم شعبي لكن
المساله الان هي كيف تقرا التعابير التي
شهدتها شوارع العاصمه باريس ومدن فرنسيه
اخرى المعارضون يرون انه يوم تاريخي فهل
تسمع الحكومه هتافات المتظاهرين
لطفي المسعودي الجزيره باريس